the brand new movie father stew about a
box returned priest starring mark
wahlberg and mel gibson has just hit
theaters for holy week our own raymond
royal sat down with the stars for an
exclusive interview along with director
roslyn ross
now gibson and wahlberg explain how
their own friendship shaped the film and
they weigh in on a surprising hollywood
fashion trend here's part two of our
interview
mel i know mark told me last time when
he was getting into this process of
investing his own cash into a passion
project he called the maestro of this
kind of deal what did you advise him at
the time
uh i said be careful but hey it's a good
idea it could go anyway there's no
there's no predicting where you'll end
up but uh i think i think he pulled the
right reign in this case
you've been working on this for years
trying to get this project made would
you have done it another way
sold the rights to somebody else and let
them do it well that was never really an
option i would have done it another way
but i think that everything happens for
a reason and and getting rosie to take
a crack at the script and then give her
her first opportunity to direct was the
absolute perfect way to make the movie
even my idea of getting sony to release
the movie having josh been you know the
head of distribution
and having released the fighter in
movies that i thought were kind of
similar in tone yeah all kind of came
together um i i want to talk about this
relationship and rosie you can jump into
this um
mel and mark famously did
daddy's home too before where he played
your father what was that experience
like
and i'll start with you why did you want
him to play your dad in this movie a
very different daddy i might add
uh well you know he uh who better for
the part i think you know to really kind
of uh
understand the subject matter what we
were trying to accomplish tonally all
that stuff but the first time around we
just had so much fun and then we were
talking about making something else that
he was going to direct that she had
already written the world war ii epic
yes yeah destroyer so we were kind of
talking about that and i was still kind
of trying to push this uphill and then i
came back to them and then
here we are why did you want to play
this dad mel this is a bit i mean he's
very understated he is not the kind of
over-the-top you know throwing it to the
wind daddy that you played in the
freezer no
he's a very deep guy but you know
a guy from montana not overly
demonstrative
but uh but but you know very still
waters run deep kind of thing and uh and
rosie wrote an excellent character you
met bill i've met him on the phone
i've only spoken to him on the phone and
i'm sure the weight of having that real
person look at your performance it does
have to
weigh on you a little bit sure it does
you know you you approach it with
trepidation i mean you're representing
someone and and you know it isn't
exactly the film doesn't represent
exactly who he was he was thrilled at
the idea of mel playing him in the movie
i mean he really got to chuckle out of
that and i remember him just kind of
laughing at stuff that i thought he
might be upset about it well the
brilliant contribution as an audience
member watching it i thought was
it plays like a comedy for the first
half of this movie it kind of takes
everybody by surprise yeah that was
deliberate yes absolutely but i i took
my cue tonally from the real guy from
stu he was an edgy guy and he had
rough sort of life experience and and he
was able to
talk to people
um
you know in a very relatable way here's
the real question how did you direct
these two guys
and what did you learn from the
experience she pushed us around um well
he's easy because i do it at home
no i you know look both both of them are
such um
dedicated prepared
um but but mostly instinctive actors and
and they're so nuanced and i think you
know it's no secret that both of them
bring a level of personal experience to
their respective roles that
inevitably
helps mark there there were some reports
that you talked to mel and got his
advice on the use of that violence and
how to use it was that is that true did
that happen i mean i think going to you
going to get permission from him about
violence it's like going to paula dean
to ask for more butter you know i mean
that's what was my first thought but we
didn't
talk about that no we just always felt
like the language and just kind of just
making it as realistic and truthful as
possible you know and we've seen i've
seen tons of faith-based movies i was
kind of getting pushed in that direction
and i don't know they all don't kind of
seem to move the needle with anybody
else unless they've already kind of
converted so
we just felt like we needed to do
something that was edgy and real and now
you deserve either life's gonna give you
a gut full of reasons to be angry
you only need one to be grateful
okay i have to get your reaction to a
few
contemporary stories before i let you go
there is a trend
among
men in your industry uh oscar isaac
harry styles wearing skirts in public to
korea now i know you weren't killed
but i killed it is that a fashion choice
you could embrace
oh it might not necessarily be i've i've
dressed up uh in my my sister's uh tutus
and ballerina costumes that was a long
time ago well
whatever you're into okay that's really
nice you're gonna dust off the old uh
william wallace outfit and
yeah i might skirt that issue
rose this came out of your pen your
heart and mind initially
what what do you want audiences to focus
on i think it it's um it's subtle but
very powerful is the message that
everyone is capable of
changing and overcoming the darkest
parts of themselves to become a better
version of themselves yeah melanie with
you at the end of the day you have no
control over the things around you but
you do have control about how you handle
it how it hits you and how you behave
and comport yourself in the midst of
chaos perhaps so it's it's uh you know
it's a good lesson i love it raymond
thank you we'll see you tomorrow night